la récréation est finie
dès ce printemps ottawa compte déposer
un projet de loi pour serrer la vis aux
grosses pointures du web
les gars femmes sont dans la mire des
législateurs l'objectif précis du
gouvernement trudeau est posée ligne de
conduite aux grandes plate forme pour
contrecarrer discours haineux des
discours violents et la pédopornographie
si le but est louable les moyens
envisagés allemande toutefois les débats
encadré internet est loin d'être simple
steven guilbeault le ministre qui pilote
ce dossier accepté de parler monsieur
guilbeault bonjour bonjour avec
bienvenue décrypteurs merci beaucoup
jusqu'à quel point il est important
d'agir contre ces discours est nous
incitent à la violence et contre la
pédopornographie c'est excessivement
c'est plus important que jamais on le
vit pendant la pandémie
toute la vague de racisme en ligne qu'on
a vues auprès des communautés asiatiques
par exemple alors tout à coup parce que
vous étiez d'origine asiatique vous
étiez responsable d'accueil de vues sur
beaucoup sur les plateformes et je pense
que ça à culminée évidemment avec ce qui
s'est passé est un point tournant
je pense que c'est l'aboutissement
ultime du lycée rallye on a laissé aux
bons soins des plateformes la
responsabilité de gérer ça lorsque je
travaillais en environnement on n'a
jamais pu me convaincre me faire une
démonstration convaincante que
l'autoréglementation pour la protection
de l'environnement ça fonctionne or je
ne pense pas que l'autoréglementation
pour la protection de nos populations
fonctionne non plus dans le domaine des
plateformes tout dépend de ce qu'on
définit comme étant un discours haineux
outre aston la ligne c'est là où je dis
que le rôle de l'état peut être perçue
par certains comme étant harbi
vers où on pourrait potentiellement
donner l'impression d'être en ligne et
sur une idéologie une approche
particulière ce que nous regardons
présentement il ya un jugement de la
cour suprême qui date de quelques amis
la cour suprême a dit voici les critères
qui vont définir ce que constitue aux
yeux de la loi un discours haineux et
donc un acte illégal et voici ce qui ne
l'est pas
alors je pense que notre plus haut
tribunal ayant ayant statué là dessus
c'est une base légale solide pour nous
pour avancer dans le cadre de ce projet
de loi la lépi siens d'y aller
concrètement une fois que les grands
principes sont acquis et puis que la
cause balles et les vertueuses quand
même
quels moyens on met en place pour que ça
marche pour que ça fonctionne tout en
respectant ses balises donc cinq choses
auxquelles on veut s'attaquer la
pornographie juvénile
l'incitation à la violence l'incitation
au terrorisme
le parcage non consensuelle d'image
comptines et finalement le discours est
donc avec le système de pénalités si je
comprends bien votre contravention
auraient non il faut prévoir ça et comme
on parle d'entreprises de très grandes
entreprises pour que les amendes soient
efficaces il faut tu dis il faut drop
que ces amendes ne soit très élevé
clairement le conseil constitutionnel en
france s'est penché sur une législation
similaire et un statut et qui aurait
risque de sur censure dans de tels cas
dans le cas d'une telle loi qu'est ce
que vous en pensez c'est ce qui est pas
un risque justement qu'on aille au delà
qui a un peu de zèle finalement l'une
des choses que l'on regarde c'est la
création d'un mécanisme qui serait qui
serait indépendant du gouvernement du
régulateur et des plateformes et qui
pourrait en recevoir des plaintes des
usagers qui estiment que leur contenu a
été enlevée d'une plateforme sans raison
sans résumé qualité d'appel le mécanisme
d'appels donc tout à fait tout à fait
indépendant un organisme sans but
lucratif
alors ce mécanisme qui permettrait à des
communautés présente donc des personnes
qui sont qui sont victimes de censure de
pouvoir faire appel ce qui ce qui est à
peu près impossible présentement dans le
contexte actuel dans un contexte
international y est toute la question la
transnationalité les postes frontières à
la désinformation au discours haineux à
l'incitation à la violence alors si les
pays agissent comme ça de façon à chacun
de son côté et de façon un peu disparate
comment assurer que tous ont une
cohérence à l'échelle mondiale parce que
comme je vous dis mais n'a pas de
frontières vous avez tout à fait raison
on peut pas penser qu'on peut arriver à
l'échelle d'un seul pays à régler ce
problème là il faut qu'ils aient cette
collaboration
internationale parce que ce problème là
on ne connaît pas de frontières mais
aussi parce qu'on voit dans certains cas
que les plateformes peuvent être est
récalcitrante même menacé certains pays
on a vu ça avec l'australie par exemple
alors je pense que certainement dans ce
dossier-là l'union fait la force
évidemment que ça se bat ça suscite un
peu d'oeuvres de réticence des dents qui
grincent un peu c'est vrai que pour une
partie d'une frange de la population
tout ça y est inacceptable il ne veut
aucune intervention qui les laisse et le
lait sert à lille le sait faire c'est ça
le principe d'internet depuis le depuis
sa création c'est s'attaquer à tout tout
un écosystème qui a toujours jouit d'une
très grande liberté
je pense qu'entre l'idéation leur rêve
qu'avait ceux et celles qui ont qui ont
qui ont collaboré à créer l'internet qui
allait être ce ce forum le libre où
toutes sortes de conversations allaient
pouvoir se tenir et le meilleur de
l'humain se manifester est ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui un monde il nous en tant que
gouvernement
ce qu'on doit faire c'est s'assurer que
les bénéfices et il ya des bénéfices que
la population profite de ses bénéfices
le maximum mais notre avance et de
limiter les effets pervers et c'est ce à
quoi ce soit qu'on s'attaque en
terminant résumé l'idée est ce qu'elle
est toujours de donner par exemple un
délai de 24 heures aux entreprises pour
qu'elles agissent
quand on détecte des contenus comme ça
sinon il y aurait pénalité est ce que
c'est un peu ça l'idée qui avait été
évoqué et qui est maintenu setc
d'enlacer dans la lettre de mandat que
le premier ministre confie c'est l'une
des tâches à laquelle je dois attaquer
et à laquelle ce projet de loi qui sera
qui sera déposé sous peu à la chambre
des communes donnera toutes les
précisions nécessaires au printemps
absolument c'est une question de
semaines
ce qui est beau merci beaucoup merci à
vous alexis prochaine bien de voir ce
projet de loi moi aussi